this is impossible the scp site director
wasn't normally a calm or cheerful man
but the researcher had rarely seen him
as angry
as he was right now his face turned a
deep
beat red as he scanned the documents on
his desk before he asked how months of
valuable research on this subject had
suddenly gone blank
the data was completely gone the
researcher gulped nervously
hoping a demotion wasn't in his future
and nodded
how could this be possible this was an
experienced researcher who should have
been taking all the necessary
precautions
could the being they were studying
somehow have erased
all these documents himself that's just
what the researcher had been trying to
find out for months
with hours and hours spent trying to
learn the extent
of its abilities well where are they the
site director asked
i want everything you have the
researcher dropped a printout of their
research on the mysterious subject's
abilities on the director's desk
every relevant line read data lost
the director let out a deep sigh he
wanted to hear
everything the researcher knew well
everything he could remember
at least from the beginning the
researcher
sat down and began to relay everything
he could about scp-343
which some of the other researchers had
started to refer to by the nickname
god scp-343 was first cited in prague
just an unassuming older man wandering
the streets
he seemed completely normal to everyone
who passed him by
until he decided he was tired of staying
on the ground
an scp agent stationed in the area
noticed the old man disappear from the
streets
as if he was blinking out of existence
only to appear
on a rooftop nearby the local scp teams
were marshalled
and they had soon tracked down what
seemed to be a very powerful specimen
but scp-343 didn't seem concerned
he reacted calmly when detained by the
foundation and went with him willingly
he was detained in a standard holding
cell for interrogation and examination
but he seemed completely at ease with
his sudden confinement
it would soon become clear that this
ordinary old man
was anything but doctors back in midlavu
was brought in to consult on the scp's
classification
and that's when the first anomalies
began their assessments matched
initially
but when it came time to describe him
physically things took a strange
turn older male seemingly non-descript
and with no unusual physical features
caucasian in appearance dr nidlovu was
confused by what dr beck was describing
in his report
this man was clearly black the two
doctors quarreled
unable to square their differing
perceptions they decided to bring in a
third impartial view to settle it
their fellow researcher dr juan she
didn't take long before coming back with
her assessment
older male seemingly nondescript and
with no unusual physical features
asian in appearance possibly chinese
whatever
scp-343 was he seemed to be perceived by
each staff member as close in appearance
to their own race
but that was only the start of the
anomalies surrounding the old man in the
holding cell
dr beck started making regular visits to
the mysterious man
and in their first interview he asked
the old man who he was
and how he came by his abilities the old
man had a simple response
i created the universe dr beck stifled
the laugh and decided to indulge the old
man's delusion
it was a fascinating claim but could he
prove
it without another word scp-343 got up
from his chair
laughed and turned around and walked
through the solid wall in the holding
cell and disappeared
dr beck was about to hit the panic
button and marshall the facility's
security to find him
when the strange man reappeared walking
through the solid wall
the only thing that was different he was
holding a hamburger which he sat down
and enjoyed the facility quickly went on
lockdown
and a full investigation was done into
how scp-343 breached containment
but there was no evidence of any
security breach no failures and
containment
and no evidence of any other cells
failing scp-343 hadn't broken through
the security
he had just ignored it as if it wasn't
there at all
when questioned about how he had gone on
his hamburger run he simply repeated his
belief that he was god
in between bites of his fast food treat
this would be far from the only time
strange things happened around scp-343
scp containment cells are as secure as
they need to be
but even the least strict containment
isn't known for its decor
which is why dr beck was in for a
surprise the next time he paid visit to
scp-343
the bare-bones cell now looked like a
comfortable home
decorated in old english fashions the
scientists assumed that scp-343 had been
making many more trips out of his cell
to get accessories
to feel more at home but that didn't
explain all the changes to the cell
no one could explain how he had
installed a roaring fireplace in the
containment cell
and everyone who entered could swear the
cell looked many times bigger than any
other cell in the facility
scp-343 wasn't just breaking containment
he now seemed to be breaking the laws of
physics in the facility
the rules of the scp containment
facility didn't seem to be a concern to
scp-343
but there was one thing he didn't seem
to want to do
escape after every sudden exit he would
always return to his personal cell
and treat it as his home when
interviewed by staff members
he was polite but vague and everyone
seemed to enjoy talking to him
it was decided to keep him on site not
attempt to increase his security
but restrict access and keep his room
guarded at all times to ensure only
researchers with level three access and
above were allowed to meet with him
but god works in mysterious ways
minimal security site 17 was one of the
least restrictive
scp containment sites hosting anomalies
that could be safely contained
and weren't likely to mount violent
escapes but as in every
scp facility security was still taken
seriously
and only those with proper clearance
could interact with the subjects
so why did scp-343 seem impossible to
guard
while only level 3 clearance and above
were allowed in the guards assigned to
protect the entrance
all seemed to fall down on the job
security officer james who was supposed
to be keeping people out of scp-343 cell
had instead let in multiple visitors in
addition to dropping in several times
himself when questioned on why he had
gone against orders and done so
he simply replied that 343 seemed lonely
and was so happy every time he got
company
that it just seemed like the right thing
to do the security guard was reassigned
and new ones were brought in
but history repeated itself guards were
given stricter instructions to minimize
exposure
but scp-343's presence always seemed to
influence them anyway his containment
cell was a revolving door
with staff members at the facility
entering regularly for friendly
conversations
dr beck decided it was time to take
matters into his own hands
he would meet with scp-343 one-on-one
and express how dangerous these security
breaches were
he would try to convince the mysterious
being that he needed to stop
influencing the minds of the guards
watching him or the facility would have
to look into new measures to contain him
dr beck entered the containment cell and
had a long conversation with
scp-343 and when he emerged
he had a big smile on his face like he
had just finished a reunion with an old
friend
he gave the current guard a friendly
clap on the back and told him not to
worry so much about
security after all nothing bad was gonna
happen from letting people at the
facility visit scp-343
right he wasn't dangerous in any way he
also said that security should bring him
anything he requests so he would feel
less need to leave a cell
minimal security site 17 soon became a
model
scp facility with morale being the
highest of any site
with most giving the credit to the
presence of scp-343
employees generally make daily visits to
his chamber and he seems to have an
encyclopedic knowledge of anything they
want to talk about
including things he should have no way
of knowing guards no longer quit their
posts or break protocol
as their only real duty is to keep track
of who meets with scp-343
so they can be interviewed and debriefed
after everyone's conversation is
different
but they all report being in a better
mood after leaving than when they came
in
no further information is available on
scp-340
origins the full extent of his powers or
whether he is telling the truth about
being the god
who created the universe the site
director rubbed his temples after
hearing the researcher's explanation
so what you're telling me is that we
have an uncontained highly powerful scp
that has not only been breaking
containment whenever it wants but has
managed to destroy
all the files regarding the research on
it the researcher's answer was yes
however the situation at seemed to be
stable
and they had come up with a plan that
should help to maximize the positive
effect
scp-343 has on the facility they were
even hypothesizing that staff from other
sites and even certain anomalies could
be pacified by 343's presence
the site director wasn't impressed
though he wanted the researcher to go
back to the drawing board and redo the
research
after all if all the files were blank
how could they ever learn how to
properly contain it
that's what the c and scp stood for
after all
containment the researcher finally had
to stand to the director though
and told them that it wasn't a good idea
that they had already tried everything
to contain
scp-343 but that it wasn't that he broke
containment
it was as if he didn't even acknowledge
that an attempt had been made to contain
him
he was omnipotent aware of things he
shouldn't
and able to do things that broke the
laws of physics without breaking a sweat
there was no evidence that this was god
the creator
of the universe as he claimed to be but
there also wasn't any evidence yet to
conclusively prove
he wasn't the researcher's best guess
was that this was a powerful reality
bender
whose abilities knew no limits and that
the only reason he was staying in the
facility was because
he wanted to and doing anything to
change that
might cause him to change his benevolent
ways the director's side
as much as he hated to admit it his
researcher was making good points
he wanted to meet scp-343 personally but
did he need to know anything first
well sir the researcher replied he likes
hamburgers
but beyond that he'll take care of the
rest he's right there where we left him
in his home waiting for his next guest
now
for a less friendly old guy in scp
custody check out
scp-106 the old man escape
and for another ancient and
uncontainable being watch
scp-3000 tashisha